according to the Centers for Disease  Control the US has seen a huge rise in  STD rates over the last four years  giant rise in STDs they're saying the  increase may be due to cuts in sex  education funding and less frequent  condom use so they say cuts in sex  education unless condom use is causing  all this and I don't know I looked into  it I think the Center for Disease  Control may be on to something  take a look at this safety first  java absolutely i got a condom now we're  ready to go this has been a message from  the Centers for Disease Control just to  remind huh it goes on your penis  that was funny though I will say that  was the least convincing doctor I've  ever seen  just a reminder let's see him again that  guy that is not a doctor whatever actor  we found to play that doctor  just a reminder it goes on your penis  [Applause]  yeah I'm a doctor what about it  you